you speak of the best sonny gray is
certainly in that category
he comes off his first win of the year
and perhaps his best start of the season
one out here in the first
and it'll bring gene segura to the plate
swing and a miss
dirt down and away segura gives himself
up first strikeout for gray
trust in the breaking ball from the
pitcher who knows it but also the hitter
knows it here though is the philly's
best hitter right now rhys hoskins
and hoskins swings and sends one in the
air lazy out to jesse winker he makes
the catch side retired sunny gray works
an effortless
one two three first noah making his 12th
start he's three and four with an era of
3.72
swung on it ripped towards second and
segura's got it on a hop he'll spin and
throw to first
and that is out number two sharply hit
yeah it was
but he's out yeah grab some pine so two
up two down that'll bring up castellanos
there's a swing and a ground ball deep
third backhand by baum he's got it low
throw to first but hoskins will dig it
out
and the side is retired we'll go to the
second in
cincinnati fred miller over for
yesterday
at the knees strike three two strikeouts
for sonny gray
set up pitch before that was the
fastball inside then the four
seamer away and there's really nothing
you're gonna do with that ball right
there
that is just a great pitch sometimes you
gotta tip your cap first bait shutter
for the philly's 30-second walk this
year
for mccutchen here's alec baum swing in
the miss
sonny gray firing the thunder gun boom
down on strikes the phillies are done in
the second
stevenson aquin and farmer do up against
aaron nola
tyler stevenson sharp ground ball right
side hole
and there's the first base hit of the
game on either side
tyler naquin the batter he does most of
his damage at home
ops at home sits over 900
905. and that one is lined
sharply to the stands right into the
moon deck
tyler naquin strikes again two
nothing reds 112 miles an hour
and aqua now 11 home runs and a team
high 37
knocked in and the kyle farmer is aboard
and it brings jonathan
india to the plate swinging the ground
ball towards the left side bombs got it
feed second there's one on to first
in time for the double play a little bit
of a low throw from segura but hoskins
able to scoop it
and get the double play to retire the
side eight nine and one
against the reds right-hander to begin
things here in the third ronald porrells
that ball was hit down the left field
line on the run is winker it
is gone a home run for torreyas
and the phillies are on the board it's a
one-run game
he just sneaks it inside the pole and i
mean just got it out right down the line
and roddy therese with his first home
run
as a philly it's been one thousand four
hundred two days
since ronald torreira's last home run
one out
and oduba herrera is coming up swung on
and hit well to
center field and going back on it and
looking up and that ball
is gone into right center oh double
herrera
with his third home run of the season
two in the frame for the phillies
and they've tied it up it's a 2-2 ball
game here in the third
88 mile an hour change up down and in
right in the nitro zone for
o'double and this left quick too reese
hoskins coming up
swinging at him as high fastball a win
out tied at two
home runs by herrera and ronald correa
suarez aboard a one out single and jesse
winker's coming up
and winker swings hits a sharp ground
ball to short torrez has it feeds segura
for one on the first double play and
they do get
that second twin killing of the night
and we'll head to the fourth inning
jt is aboard brad miller is the batter
in the pitch
soaking that on the inside edge
elbows flying strike three six k's for
sonny gray
andrew mccutchen is walking off the mask
of barnhart
and jt will go to third barnard has no
idea where it is
maybe that baseball knocked him loopy
wow is that his feet the whole time yeah
he should know as good as the catcher is
it ain't going to go far
hit him in the mask infield in a wild
pitch
count has gone full on mccutcheon again
payoff
sharp ground ball nice diving stop by
suarez looks back real mute oh and makes
the throw
of a sensational play by geno suarez
yes gino yes yes and yes
hot corner smash great reaction check
the runner
fire a strike to first base yes sir so
he's still there at third base now two
outs and alec balm to the plate
oh pitch off the hands out toward left
that's going to drop in for a base hit
rbi
single real muto scores and the phillies
take the lead
here the fourth inning and man that has
to feel good for alec bowman ends an old
for 12.
bottom of the fourth phillies lead three
to two nick castiano's
entered on a 17-game hit
through streak hole base hit an 18-game
hit streak for nick castiano's
the longest by a red since 2007.
here's tyler stevenson breaking ball cut
out and missed
first strikeout for aranola and it comes
at an opportune time
one out here in the fourth and it's his
999th
career strikeout two on one out and the
batter will be kyle farmer
breaking ball ground ball third base
boom's got it to second there's one on
the first double play it's the third one
turned tonight for the phillies third
inning in a row that they turned two on
the reds
so one away top of the order now oh
double herrera
swing of the miss eight strikeouts for
sonny gray
two outs in the inning three two
phillies lead it reese hoskins the
batter
3-2 pitch lined out toward left field
and it's over the head of winker and off
the wall he's kicking it around
segora scores easily reece hoskins to
second base with an rbi
double 4-2 phillies he's extended his
hitting streak to 10 straight games with
his double
the 100th double of his career we go to
the bottom of the fifth it's 4-2 phil's
india has an easy steal of second one
and two on freeman
that is hammered over second right
center base hit wave is on for india
ball just now gathered by herrera
a turn and hold at first by freeman
india scores
and the reds draw within a run four to
three lead runner down to second he's
the tying run
it'll bring up jesse winker aaron only
has one strikeout
it was number 999 for his career payoff
pitch
swinging a miss he struck him out
and there is strikeout number one
thousand
for erin nolta in his career he is the
fastest
philly ever to get to a thousand
strikeouts and he needed that one for
sure they go to the sixth
embry will go to work against andrew
mccutchen
that one is smoked deep to left field it
is
gone long run for andrew mccutchen
his eighth of the year the phillies get
the run
back 5-3 phillies on top ronald teres is
the batter
home back out to his lead that one's
out toward left center field that's
going to split the gap and go to the
wall
balms to third he's being waved home
thereas
will stop at second it's an rbi double
ronald teres with his
second rbi of the night it's 6-3 fills
well herrera with a rudder at third one
out
that one's golfed deep to right field
no doubt about it the second home run of
the night for o'double herrera
and the phillies have scored eight runs
they lead it eight to three it's a four
run sixth inning hard single by segura
hoskins the batter he's one for three
the pitch
and he swings and lifts it in the air
deep to right castiano's back
track wall it's gone rhys hoskins has
gone deep to the opposite field
it's his 12th of the year another home
run
third one of the inning for the phillies
phillies have two on with one out and
now andrew mccutchen will stand in
that one is pulled deep to left field
toward the corner
it is gone second home run of the night
for andrew mccutchen that's a three-run
bomb
and the fills have extended their lead
to 10.
alex blandino returns to the mouth got
the final out of the eight
so that'll load the bases and it'll
bring up matt joyce who walked
and scored in the eighth inning hung on
and hit high in the air
deep right field and that one is gonna
go
matt joyce with a grand slam
here in the ninth inning for matt joyce
it's his second
homer and the phillies lead it 17-3
here in the night kinsler who can get
some double play balls
tucker barnhart's the batter and the
phillies have turned four double plays
already in this one
ground ball second base mata
to second for one over to first in time
of four
six three double play five double plays
tonight
as they win it convincingly
17-3